[Musique]
le 21 août 1940 Leon Trotski l'un des
acteurs emblématiques de la Révolution
bolchevik était donc sauvagement
assassinés à Mexico d'un coup de piolet
un assassinat commandité par Staline et
fomenté par les services secrets
soviétiques que viennent nous raconter
ce documentaire réalisé par Marie Brunet
debenne en collaboration avec Éline
kirschwink mais que reste-t-il
aujourd'hui du troskillisme c'est la
question que nous allons nous poser
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de débat doc avec que vous
pour commencer Jean Louma Dukan
bienvenue à vous vous êtes historien
enseignant à l'université de Rouen
spécialiste de la gauche française et
germanophone et de l'histoire du
marxisme on vous doit entre autres
histoire globale des socialistes un
ouvrage publié au presse universitaire
de France et votre dernier ouvrage
s'intitule quant à lui la République
ensanglantée Berlin Vienne aux sources
du nazisme disponibles chez Armand Colin
Jean-Christophe oui c'est également avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes ancien premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste ancien
député socialiste de Paris et votre
dernier ouvrage parle de votre parcours
politique bien entendu qui commencera
justement chez les troskis c'était en
1971 je crois et s'intitule hier
aujourd'hui et demain une vie politique
dans le roman de la gauche d'un ouvrage
disponible chez va édition et puis enfin
avec nous Christophe Bourseiller
bienvenue Christophe Bourseiller merci à
vous d'être dans cette émission c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous y accueillir
vous êtes tout à la fois acteur
journaliste écrivain vous êtes l'un des
tous meilleurs spécialiste de l'extrême
gauche de l'ultra gauche en France en
lui ayant consacré un bon nombre
d'ouvrages dont celui-ci nouvelle
histoire de l'ultra gauche disponible
aux éditions du Cerf avant de parler du
trosky ce qui est notre sujet après ce
documentaire avec cette question
existe-t-il du troskisme aujourd'hui on
va bien sûr parler d'abord de Léon
trosky puisque c'est lui qui est mis en
avant bien entendu dans ce documentaire
que diriez-vous de ceux qui pensent que
trosky a été assassiné qu'il est mort en
martyr d'un rêve trahi sanctifié par
l'idée selon laquelle et bien sa
victoire sur Staline eu sans doute
empêcher le cauchemar de la dictature
soviétique est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça est-ce que c'est cela qui
exprime trop ce qui dans l'esprit
peut-être de d'être huskyme Trotsky a
été l'emblème à partir de la fin des
années 20 pour toute une série de
militants voulant continuer à se
réclamer du communisme du socialisme
l'emblème d'un résistant de l'Intérieur
en Union soviétique qui était contre le
cours stalinien pour le diabit alors
est-ce qu'il aurait suffi que Trotski
est telle ou telle position de pouvoir à
un moment donné pour changer le cours de
l'histoire de l'Union soviétique je
crois que c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué que cela en revanche
publier certains c'est que Trotsky a
théorisé un certain nombre de points sur
la question de l'État ouvrier est-ce que
l'Union soviétique pouvait être encore
défendue sur un certain nombre de points
certains pensaient que comme c'était la
dictature stalinienne il n'y avait
absolument plus rien à sauver Trotski si
vous voulez est un opposant de
l'Intérieur d'abord en Union soviétique
puis même lorsqu'il est expulsé en
pensant que il demeure des basses
sociales et politiques minimales en
Union soviétique notamment la propriété
publique qui font que on peut défendre
le RSS mais on ne peut plus défendre la
direction stalinienne c'est ça qui a
incarné Trotski d'abord sur le moment et
pour des générations de militants
ensuite qui ne voulaient pas renoncer et
rompre avec l'héritage de la révolution
de 1917 la Révolution d'Octobre dont les
autres skis a été un des acteurs majeurs
comme chef de l'Armée rouge on l'a bien
vu dans le reportage il y avait l'idée
que l'Union soviétique était un projet
politique qui avait dévié de son chemin
initial et c'est ça la différence entre
le trots mais d'autres courants plutôt
libertaire ou d'extrême gauche qui
voudront totalement rompre avec que
l'histoire soviétique en considérant
qu'il n'y avait que rien à sauver si un
élément essentiel je crois qui définit
Trotski le trots de cette époque là on
dit aussi beaucoup que Trotsky n'était
pas un ange que c'était même un
personnage assez effrayant assez
impitoyable envers ses ennemis écrasant
ses opposants alors ça a été vrai durant
la guerre civile bien entendu et au tout
début de cette révolution bolchevik
Trotsky a été à la tête de l'Armée rouge
il a mené effectivement de manière
totalement implacable la guerre civile
bon je rappelle il y avait une guerre
civile intérieure en dans la jeune
Russie soviétique il y avait des
interventions d'armée étrangères et
Trotsky d'ailleurs pour faire pour
battre les armées étrangères pour battre
les armées qui étaient hostiles sur son
sol à même appelé les anciens généraux
de sa liste pour les réintégrer dans
l'armée pour avoir une armée
suffisamment forte pour pouvoir gagner
sur place donc c'est dire à quel point
effectivement trop de ski on l'oublie
parfois parce qu'effectivement après il
y a une figure un peu romantique du
Trotsky
il a un peu joué incontestablement
tout à fait dans ma vie quelques années
plus tard effectivement mais Trotski est
un chef militaire tout à fait aussi
assez impressionnant par même à
l'histoire à l'échelle du 20e siècle
pour autant dire alors Jean-Christophe
vous adhérez donc vous tout d'abord à
l'alliance des jeunes pour le socialisme
qui était la structure un jeune du de
l'organisation communiste
internationaliste l'océi qui est devenu
elle-même le Parti communiste
internationaliste tout ça se passe en
1971 pour vous vos débuts chez est-ce
que vous aviez une fascination pour le
personnage dont on vient de parler pour
Léon trosky à l'époque tout à fait parce
que le trots pour moi commence dans
l'exil avant il n'y a pas trop ce qui il
est même chez Vic internationaliste
à Lénine sur que faire et la conception
du parti
centralisée il participe de la
révolution russe il est la guerre civile
on vient de le dire évidemment avec tout
ce que cela veut dire
de répression de cronstad des
anarchistes de la lutte contre macno qui
est dans un autre anarchisme mais en
Ukraine où il est né et puis il s'oppose
à la mort de Lénine à Staline qui va
prendre le pouvoir et il va commencer
une écriture de ce qu'aurait pu être le
communisme et dans cette écriture il va
révéler les crimes de salie ce que
Personne n'avait fait jusqu'au
auparavant plusieurs volumes sur
l'ensemble des procès de Moscou il va
contester la politique de
l'international communiste en Chine il
va fonder la Quatrième internationale en
disant que à partir du moment où Staline
et Hitler font un pacte pas que
germanossoviétique la guerre va venir et
qu'il faut se préparer à la suite de la
guerre et donc
comme ça au début des années 70
chez vous ça c'est parce que nous vous
faisons une adhésion
nous nous avons une vingtaine d'années
nous faisons partie de ce grand
mouvement de l'ensemble de la jeunesse
poste 68 armes à l'échelle
internationale que ce soit les
mouvements d'Amérique latine au Japon en
Allemagne en France évidemment sur les
campus américains et dans ce mouvement
général il y a une cristallisation trots
extrêmement forte en France et je
rencontre à l'université des militants
trosquistes militants de la Quatrième
Internationale et j'adhère à ce
mouvement et immédiatement ce qui me
fait adhérer c'est la lecture de
l'histoire de la Révolution russe de
Léon Trotski qui est à mon avis même si
on est loin du trotisme comme moi
aujourd'hui un chef-d'oeuvre du point de
vue de l'analyse à la fois politique
humaine psychologique et sociales d'une
révolution et vous rejoindrez les le
Parti socialiste bien plus tard en 86 on
y reviendra tout à l'heure on va revoir
juste un extrait Christophe boursier du
documentaire c'est ce que pense en
réalité les entreski de Staline
il me répugné par les traits de
caractère qui ont fait ensuite sa force
dans la vague de décadence et trois
tests des intérêts empirisme
psychologique grossière un singulier
cynisme de provincial
[Musique]
les deux hommes s'opposaient aussi sur
l'idéologie révolutionnaire
trop de ski prenait une révolution
mondiale
Staline voulait s'en tenir à la
révolution russe qui était désormais
achevée
[Musique]
alors dans cette période qui vient
d'évoquer Jean-Christophe
gambadélisendront en tout cas on va
parler des années 60 et moi je veux bien
venir sur 70 sur ce qu'on vient de dire
parce que on peut pas en profiter de
puis ensuite je voudrais vous demander
quelque chose oui mais je voudrais bien
il faut bien comprendre une chose c'est
que quand Staline tue trop de ski en
réalité strosky ne le menace pas Staline
et paranoïaque le trots de cette époque
là c'est minuscule contre ce qui monte
l'opposition de gauche internationale en
1929 ils sont 70 sur toute la planète
c'est un courant
ultra minoritaire quand il monte la
Quatrième internationale en 1938 c'est
un mouvement c'est un petit peu remplumé
parce qu'une section américaine qui est
même pas forte de mille membres qui
s'appelle le socialisme workers Party
qui est un peu plus forte et qui va
remplir ce groupe mais créer la
Quatrième Internationale ça veut être
faiblesse parce que Trotski voulait au
départ faire une révolution politique
dans la Troisième Internationale dans
l'International communiste et donc le
trots c'est une culture minoritaire
c'est des gens qui veulent faire la
révolution qui veulent brandir le un pot
de la flamme a vaincu mais en réalité
ils sont très peu nombreux et toute leur
logique politique c'est une logique
minoritaire c'est pour ça qu'ils vont
les voix après toujours rentrer dans des
groupes ils fonctionnent de cette
manière-là parce que ils sont été
décimés dans les années 1930 et 1940 et
ils sont en réalité ils ont toujours été
très très peu nombreux par rapport au
gigantesque Parti communiste staliniens
des années 30-40 et 50 je voudrais juste
préciser une chose parce que évidemment
c'est des courants qui ont toujours été
pratiquement minoritaires sauf dans de
rares exceptions mais vous savez on
retrouve encore des documents
aujourd'hui dans les jaunes cette
fois-ci le Poutine dans les prisons
sibériennes ou dans l'Oural des cahiers
des archives etc de militants qui
étaient dans l'opposition de gauche au
début des années 30 donc c'est avant les
grandes purges de 1936 ou 37 où là
effectivement tout le monde est décimé
où on trouve des gens qui sont pourtres
ce qui là on va pas les qualifier de
Trotski c'est ta proprement parler parce
qu'en plus le propre du stalinisme ce
sera après d'accuser n'importe qui de
trots dans n'importe quoi mais il y a eu
un mouvement d'opposition fort dont on
ne peut pas connaître exactement les
tenants les aboutissants surtout mais il
y a une vraie véritable résistance à la
montée du stalinisme en Union soviétique
et qui s'est notamment incarné dans la
figure de Trotsky ça veut pas dire
qu'effectivement les Trotski c'était
aussi fort que ça mais on peut pas non
plus dire qu'ils étaient juste quelques
dizaines dans les années 30 après l'exil
on parle du trosky après l'église c'est
une culture
c'est des groupuscules les parties
trotiques dans les années
c'est pas le cas je parle surtout de la
France effectivement il est en Espagne
il y a un parti qui n'est pas vraiment
trop de skis qui est le chemin est parti
ouvrier
tout de même avancer un tout petit peu
dans le temps et la question que je
voulais vous poser c'est dans cette
période
1960-1970 que vient d'évoquer
Jean-Christophe Cambadélis et après
avoir vu l'extrait qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure et ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
l'anti stalinisme qui constituait
l'entrée principale pour aller vers le
troskillisme dans cette période précise
de notre histoire alors pour vous
répondre très précisément ça dépendait
des groupes et des courants c'est à dire
que tous les groupes trots qui sont
apparus dans les années 1970 au début
des années 1970 était les héritiers de
traditions beaucoup plus anciennes vous
prenez par exemple le groupe Lutte
ouvrière était l'héritier d'un groupe
Barta enfin bref lutte de classe qui
était fondée en 1939 les la Quatrième
Internationale incarnée à l'époque par
la Ligue communiste plongeait ses
racines dans cette quatrième
internationale fondée en 1938 et quant
au courant lambertiste dont faisait
partie Jean-Christophe Cambadélis
l'organisation communiste
internationaleiste il plongeait ses
racines dans une scission de la mer
internationale en 1952 et donc vous avez
Lutte ouvrière qui eux étaient plus dans
l'idée de maintenir le flambeau d'un pur
communisme dégagé de toute scories vous
aviez les lambertistes qui ont été
véritablement
c'était vraiment le moteur principal la
lutte je crois le cette dimension anti
stalinienne et puis vous aviez les les
ceux que les lentilles s'appelaient les
pablistes qui étaient les disciples de
Pierre franc en réalité Pablo avait fait
partie et qui était donc la Ligue
communiste qui était entre les deux
c'est à dire qui était à la fois dans la
comment dirais-je l'attaque contre le
stalinisme et en même temps dans une
défense de l'Union soviétique donc ils
étaient à mi-chemin si vous voulez cette
opposition entre
les stars les staliniens et les
troschistes on la retrouve presque
jusqu'à nos jours aujourd'hui c'est à
dire qu'on est anti-communiste et on est
plutôt trop de kyste la configuration a
quand même beaucoup changé depuis
l'effondrement de l'URSS puissent
effectivement même le cadre mental et
politique dans lequel Trotski évoluait
quand je vous disais tout à l'heure il
parlait d'État ouvrier dégénéré pour
qualifier l'Union soviétique pour dire
que l'URSS avait dévié de sa route avec
la bureaucratie stalinienne mais qu'il y
avait des bases sociales et politiques à
sauver malgré surtout évidemment la
configuration du débat n'est plus la
même à partir du moment où le principal
pays concerné et les pays satellites
autour ce sont effondrés donc de ce
point de vue là on a retrouvé par
exemple des convergences ensuite penser
au traité de Maastricht en 1992 donc
juste après l'effondrement de l'URSS de
décembre 1991 dans le nom entre
guillemets de gauche à Maastricht vous
avez des trots donc ceux qui sont au
courant issus du courant lambertiste qui
sont pour le nom à Maastricht et vous
avez le PCF qui est non à Maastricht à
ce moment-là il y a même des embryons de
campagne communes chose qui aurait été
inenvisageable dans les années 1970 donc
là on a même eu des rapprochements dans
des cadres syndicaux des cadres
parapolitiques entre entre guillemets
ceux qui sont issus du stalinisme et
ceux issus du trotisme parce que tout
simplement les enjeux ne sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes ça n'invalide pas les
débats historiques ça n'invalide pas les
responsabilités des uns et des autres à
un moment donné ça ne valide pas ce à
quoi faisait référence Jean-Christophe
comadélis tout à l'heure sur l'histoire
du commun interne et de l'international
communiste parce que on est dans un
monde de plus en plus connecté avec des
gauches qui doivent se parler les unes
et les autres aux quatre coins du monde
donc cette histoire là demeure
intéressante quand bien même elle est
marquée par une empreinte évidemment qui
n'a pas grand chose à voir avec
certaines réalités contemporaines alors
Jean-Christophe cambadelli je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure vous rejoignez le Parti
socialiste en
19046 soit 3 ans avant la chute du mur
et vous le faites pas seul parce que
vous amenez avec vous
400 personnes qui aussi étaient
d'oédiens tropsiste pourquoi ce choix
est-ce que vous considérez que le
logiciel troskiste n'était plus du tout
à l'ordre du jour à la fin de ces années
80 alors c'est un choix faudrait du
temps pour l'expliquer mais c'est un
choix qui est global d'une génération
parce que c'est principalement des
étudiants beaucoup de syndicalistes
aussi des personnalités extrêmement
connues aujourd'hui qui vont venir avec
moi créer une organisation qui s'appelle
Convergence socialiste puis
aller au Parti socialiste pourquoi parce
que dans d'abord il y a un cheminement
par rapport au marxisme un cheminement
intellectuel pas simplement le trots par
rapport au marxisme matérialisme
historique etc tout ceci est questionné
par un certain nombre de responsables de
ce courant et puis on est dans une
contradiction dans cette formation qui
est un peu militaire je l'explique dans
mon livre extrêmement
secrète mais surtout organiser
militairement qui est articulé autour
d'un chef qui est Pierre Lambert Lambert
qui développe une théorie comme quoi
Mitterrand et Le Pen c'est la même chose
et nous nous pensons à cette époque
qu'on peut pas mettre le même sur le
même plan François Mitterrand et
Jean-Marie Le Pen et que à sa manière on
va dire François Mitterrand défend la
gauche et à partir de là la rupture se
fait d'abord elle se constitue
clandestinement à l'intérieur de cette
organisation c'est ce qui a fait un peu
l'INT à la sortie parce que nous étions
organisés clandestinement dans cette
organisation puis nous créons une
nouvelle formation puis cette formation
se pose le problème de son devenir et on
ne se voyait pas reconstruire la
Quatrième Internationale à 400 et donc
on a réfléchi à ce que vous pouvez faire
il y en a décidé de rentrer dans le
Parti socialiste et quand on est rentré
dans le Parti socialiste tout le monde
sait éparpillé dans la nature du Parti
socialiste qui est fort large alors
lorsqu'on parle des anciens de l'océan
on évoque c'est vrai souvent votre nom
celui de Lionel Jospin et aussi celui de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on en reparlera
est-ce que c'est pas de l'ordre du
fantasme l'entrisme
concernant le troskill dans les
formations politiques et pas seulement
aussi les syndicats étudiants lunettes
bien sûr vous êtes bien placé pour le
savoir Jean-Christophe Cambadélis
l'entrée dans le domaine du fantasme
parce que quand on quitte à 400 une
organisation pas des 400
la relocérance par contre de ce que
Jean-Christophe comme délice oublie de
dire c'est que dans les 400 il y avait
des gens qui étaient à la tête de la
Ligue des droits de l'homme il y en
avait un qui était directeur de cabinet
de Jack Lang ministère de la Culture il
y avait des gens qui étaient qui avaient
des fonctions moi j'ai connu un ancien
lambertiste qui avait été sous préférée
évidemment il disait pas qu'il était
lambertise quand il était sous-préfet
mais il y a beaucoup et partout oui il y
avait cette culture là et je crois que
cette culture là elle s'explique par
cette culture de la minorité qui
caractérise vraiment l'idéal trots
depuis le départ le fait d'être en
danger en permanence parce que
l'estalinien voulait les tuer le fait
d'être si peu nombreux et de vouloir
peser sur la société quand on est si peu
nombreux et ce qui fait que c'est
Trotski qui va dire en 1934 aux militant
drots français adhéré aux parties
socialistes adhérer ce parti parce que
d'abord ça va permettre de d'être dans
un parti ouvrier dégénéré pour le peut
générer de l'intérieur et puis ça va
vous permettre d'échapper éventuellement
à l'assassinat donc il y avait cette
double dimension à partir de la fin des
années 80
c'est que c'est pas les trots qui ont
inventé l'entrée c'est-à-dire que Lénine
déjà avant avait préconisé des
stratégies d'entrée notamment par
exemple en Angleterre où il avait dit
aux communistes anglais adhérer aux
parties travaillées parce que vous êtes
trop peu nombreux cela dit affirmin cela
dit quand
l'entrisme est devenu une pratique qui
s'est généralisée et qui a je crois
contribuer beaucoup à au fait de je
dirais elle a eu une influence
culturelle cette pratique je m'explique
je crois que aujourd'hui le trots est
présent en France sous la forme d'un
certain nombre d'habitudes sous la forme
de réflexe idéologique sous une forme
fait je crois que le le trots parle en
triste pas beaucoup contribué à sans
doute radicaliser la gauche beaucoup
contribué à une évolution des mœurs et
je crois qu'il y a une vraie influence
culturelle du trots faut pas être
conspiratif sur cette question là parce
que vous savez être une taupe c'est très
difficile mentalement alors j'aimerais
avoir votre avis parce que oui ce que
vous avez bien fait de rappeler le la
stratégie de Trotsky lui-même disant il
faut rentrer dans le Parti socialiste
quand plus rien d'autre n'est possible
puisqu'à l'époque retourner dans le
parti communiste c'était impossible
beaucoup s'en étaient fait exclure et
beaucoup font le choix d'aller dans le
Parti socialiste pour construire entre
guillemets une aile gauche et c'est
relativement la même démarche qui
consiste à dire pour les trots nous
allons aller dans les syndicats de masse
par exemple les grands syndicats nous
allons pas essayer de créer des petits
syndicats alors dans l'histoire du trots
il y en a qui vont faire des petits
syndicats plutôt radicaux ils vont finir
par le faire certains mais si vous êtes
entre guillemets un peu fidèle à la
lettre même la stratégie des débuts de
l'international communiste après l'échec
de la révolution en Europe occidentale
notamment en Allemagne c'était dire ouh
là là si je puis dire ne nous coupons
pas des masses les masses sont encore
structurées par les grands partis
politiques socialiste communiste donc
nous nous allons aller dans la en France
dans la CGT les grands syndicats pour
animer des ailes gauche pour essayer de
conquérir les ouvriers et les ouvrières
et de faire en sorte qu'ils aient soit
le plus à gauche possible c'est la
différence avec d'autres courants
d'extrême gauche dans d'autres pays qui
vont créer des syndicats rouges des
petites choses etc très radicales alors
que les trots cherchent plutôt
historiquement à influer le grand cours
des choses en étant présent dans les
grandes organisations en essayant des
enfluer alors
pour parce qu'on a été là-dessus pour
parler de l'entrisme c'est pas une
décision d'entrée dans le parti
socio-démocrates en soi en France au
moment où la question se pose il y a à
l'intérieur de la SFIO une gauche dites
révolutionnaire une gauche socialiste
marsupiler aux irons de ski suivant les
cas c'est de
tendance de courant de sensibilité on
dirait aujourd'hui qui sont assez
puissantes qui dirigent un certain
nombre de fédérations et il s'agit en
plus que Trotski avait des contacts avec
eux deux les accompagner de
d'accompagner leur mouvement de rupture
possible parce que le schéma est
toujours le même c'est la rupture avec
les appareils qui doit conduire à
aux parties révolutionnaire et et faire
en sorte que celui-ci puisse agir dans
la révolution ça existe toujours
aujourd'hui
si vous essayez de mettre le schéma tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui l'idée au fond de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est le fait que des
ailes du Parti communiste des
écologistes et de la social-démocratie
vont se déplacer et venir
à la France insoumise et créer le
mouvement qui va aider à la processus au
processus d'une révolution citoyenne
pour lui ou parlementaires pour changer
les bases de la société c'est exactement
le même schéma alors vous nous amener
aujourd'hui ça tombe bien il nous reste
cinq minutes reste-t-il du troskisme
Christophe bourse-t-il du trots je crois
une influence culturelle assez forte
j'ai une présence une culture trotskiste
qu'on retrouve chez beaucoup de gens de
gauche qui peuvent être aussi bien au PS
à Europe Écologie Les Verts chez les
insoumis autour de Mélenchon ou ailleurs
et c'est une façon de parler une façon
de voir les choses une vision du monde
et je crois que il contribue largement à
radicaliser cette gauche et puis il
reste des parties trots
à chaque présidentielle
un candide une candidate en l'occurrence
Nathalie
donc l'Union communiste est inaltérable
et continue son petit bonhomme de chemin
le NTA le NPA anciennement Ligue
communiste révolutionnaire de NPA
justement est un bon exemple de de cette
complexité des stratégies parce que les
militants français de la Quatrième
internationale sont en partie dans le
NPA et en partie dans le collectif
ensemble qui est membre des insoumis et
qui soutient François Ruffin donc c'est
voyez que si vous allez sur le site
Clémentine ou Clémentine quand vous
allez sur le site de la 4e
internationale du bureau exécutif
international vous voyez une double
section vous voyez donc c'est ambigu et
quand au Lamberti s'ils ont été ils ont
été ébranlés par une scission en 2015
qui les a un peu affaibli mais
aujourd'hui le le on pourrait dire une
tendance un peu plus entre guillemets
raisonnable autre qui s'appelle le Parti
ouvrier indépendant et qui roule pour
Mélenchon ils sont complètement avec
Mélenchon et un député ici Monsieur
Lagrave le grave qui est du POI qui est
donc dans cette alliance de la nupes
alors que reste-t-il du trosky je vous
la pose à vous aussi je pense qu'il faut
quand même faire une distinction entre
effectivement celles et ceux qui ont été
trop ski c'était qui ont complètement
fait autre chose après ça vient d'être
rappelé et puis c'est vrai que certains
il y a l'influence culturelle bon moi je
sais c'est toujours difficile à mesurer
parce qu'on pourrait dire dans ce cas là
il y a une influence culturelle aussi de
sociale démocratie de ceux qui sont
issus du Parti communiste on parle pas
mais plus trop de ski mais Mélenchon
de parler une façon de se comporter qui
est véritablement dans l'héritage
lambertiste oui mais en même temps moi
si vous vous souvenez de ce texte qu'il
avait fait publié en 2015 de hareng de
Bismarck c'était un texte qui était
contre la politique d'Angela Merkel qui
pour moi était un texte assez
farouchement nationaliste assez
germanophobes assez hallucinant sur un
certain nombre de points ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas critiquer la
politique de l'Allemagne ça me paraît
très très loin des envolés
internationalistes absolues qui avaient
pas beaucoup
avec moi
et la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est que vous avez un certain nombre
d'organisations qui seraient comme du
troskis qui continuent à exister et la
plupart des militants qui sont dans ces
organisations sont plutôt des
syndicalistes si souvent beaucoup dans
la fonction publique c'est vrai parce
que c'est là où c'est plus facile aussi
d'exercer je crois qu'il faut mettre
différents niveaux quoi sinon on
comprend pas les choses etc mais après
voilà parce que il faut quand même on a
parlé d'un héritage on a parlé d'un
personnage d'un héritage politique de
différents courants et de ceux qui en
sont issus et ça il y a une
particularité française par rapport à
d'autres pays même d'Europe occidentale
qui est que les courants trots ont été
assez forts dans l'extrême gauche mais
ils ont fait jusqu'à 10% à la
présidentielle en 2002 dans les années
70 c'est controversé mais enfin on dit
que le ci était pas loin c'était parti
des 10000 donc c'était quand même des
milliers de militants et souvent très
aguerris des cadres syndicaux beaucoup
moins nombreux que les militants du PCF
mais souvent très aguerris très bon pour
occuper des positions syndicales et
politiques et ça il en reste
effectivement encore quelque chose pro
et d'ailleurs au Congrès Liévin congrès
du Parti socialiste d'administroscan
dont vous aviez été proche après c'était
étonné de la de la présence et de la
puissance d'être husky dans les
instances dirigeants du PS et Filoche
qui qui lui
a vérifié avec deux ministres scan à
l'époque et sur 70 représentants des
instances dirigeantes du PS en 94 35
venait du trosky oui mais parce que le
trosky c'est à la fois une mémoire une
méthode et une présence la mémoire
revient d'en parler la méthode c'est
l'intégration dans la politique du
rapport de force
la compréhension que les événements sont
pluriels une conception stratégique
toujours quand vous entendez discuter de
stratégie vous pouvez vous dire qu'il y
a une formation et un noyau trosquisant
qui est là et puis la passion
des structures et la présence
aujourd'hui c'est une présence syndicale
aujourd'hui les trosquées sont
principalement non plus dans le
mouvement social mais principalement
investis dans les organisations syndicat
en particulier
un moment donné et donc il y a pu
d'opposition de gauche dans la CFDT
enfin d'ultra gauche
et par exemple au moment de de la loi
travail au congrès de la CGT les trots
font passer une motion de congrès de
Marseille pour la grève générale
battant l'appareil anciennement du Parti
communiste mais ça n'existe plus
paraît-il donc on voit leur présence et
leur puissance dans le monde
parlait tout à l'heure de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et de ses réflexes lambertiste
y compris aujourd'hui il avait rejoint
le Parti socialiste 10 ans avant en 76
en occupant avec la gauche socialiste
l'aile gauche du Parti socialiste à
l'époque est-ce que est-ce que dans le
logiciel Jean-Luc Mélenchon est dans le
logiciel lambertiste il y a pas une
chose importante à retenir c'est qu'ils
veulent la fin des sociotes ils veulent
la fin des sociaux-démocrates et est-ce
que c'est pour ça que vous dites
attention aujourd'hui à la méchante
mélenchonisation des esprits c'est ce
que vous dites en ce moment bien sûr
parce que il y a aujourd'hui une
[Musique]
place qui est disproportionnée de la
France insoumise et de Mélenchon dans
l'ensemble de la gauche parce que il y a
eu la nupesse on est dans une situation
où les parties de gauche
pspcf c'est maintenant un peu différent
et depuis le congrès de d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts ça va être différente
pour les écologistes mais qui est sous
la domination intellectuelle et
politique de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui ne
développe pas une théorie ou une des
thèse trots puisque lui c'est le
populisme de gauche donc il a modifié
entièrement le logiciel il y a des
éléments qui sont communs évidemment
mais il a modifié le logiciel qui était
le alors les années 70
non mais je suis je suis d'accord avec
ce qu'un maintenant rien ne prouve que
la gauche en se trots va être gagnante
c'est plutôt le contraire d'accord
est-ce qu'on peut comparer les coups
contre ce qui c'est avec les actuels
positions populistes de gauche de
Mélenchon je pense que sérieusement il y
a une vraie présence Trotski autour de
Mélenchon tout à fait tout à fait tout à
fait bon ça sera le mot de la fin
vraiment un grand merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission des
Badoc aujourd'hui avec cette question un
corps reste-t-il du trosky enfin après
ce documentaire consacré à léontrosky
que nous avons eu l'occasion de vous
proposer dans cette émission vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
sur Twitter mais on a vu elles ne vont
pas manquer aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je
compte sur vous pour réagir à ce que
sont les les réactions merci aussi à
Selma Sally qui comme à l'accoutumée m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission puis je
vous donne rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat très bientôt
[Musique]